yeah
it was 62 minutes exactly nothing should
be longer than a go more girl hi thank
you can you put these under Billy
Eichner ladies here
oh I'm just assuming anyways the movie
probably felt so long because it was so
problematic totally and but like how
would you say it was well I mean it was
some racist to Italians yeah well we
both hate racism yeah so tell me how
about yourself like where do you live
what kind of beds in there well I have a
king-size bed I live in Midtown East no
I'm not going there
great party
oh great party great party dude this is
a great party
glad to having fun man oh no no I'm uh
I'm auditioning for commercial I'm an
actor I actually went to the same
theatre school as Patrick Wilson's
cousin but I'm in New York now mostly
doing theater or I want to start doing
more theater oh my god is Common Pleas
so tragic I know and in this climate
exactly hi I'm Brooke I was gonna wear
jeans to this cuz I'm rich but I just
thought that was too obvious so that's
why I'm in this huge gown our friends
either was just talking about not having
a job we'd what oh my god that makes me
feel so much better I don't have a job
either yeah I'm kind of spinning out
about what I'm gonna do this azita relax
you don't have to do anything
they're cool this is the beauty of
retirement you're retired yeah of course
you know how it goes your teens are for
working your 20s are for resting well
what are your 30s for maybe the global
impact Brooke thank God
oh this party is not fun yes it is I'm
having fun you are
well not like fun fun but you know party
but what what party fun when everybody
the party just agrees to perform fun at
each other and it's the collective
effort that makes it fun
you know they could put this little
model girl she's not having fun fun yes
I am okay yeah but you know when you're
alone with your thoughts in bed tonight
you're not
was back at this party and think that
was fun fun yes I will
I'm having the time of my life and I'll
think back often to just how much fun
this all was okay well she's a model she
doesn't know her own brain I'm not a
model I'm an EP on the film Jesus
okay well your movies racist yeah so now
I'm focusing on theater mostly
celebrities are I thought tensley
Mortimer was here oh I think she got
turned away at the door
I haven't seen cheese dreams it either I
wanted a picture you did yeah I mean I
haven't I haven't seen him in a while
but if I do I'll send him your way what
was your name Brittany and thank you
I love taste dreams he's like the cutest
boy in the whole world
cutest boy everyone is saying I should
incorporate but I don't know if it's
worth it I think it is so you could
deduct all your business expenses think
about every time you fly I just feel so
dumb about this stuff like should I get
an LCU or an escort what do you have
you know actually I don't I don't think
I'd get either in this climate
hey Streeter I can't find you guys can
you put chase on chase can't talk right
now his neck is bound what yeah I'm just
trying to keep his Adam's apple under
control got to keep that neck looking
young and slick oh don't do that where
are you we're on a plane to Pittsburgh
what yeah he's got a concert at 9:00 how
he has one song still tearing it up at
the AP the after power tag
I'm sure Brooke is she loves this kind
of stuff she's probably having fun
around here somewhere well um this woman
named Britt Lynn wanted a photo with
chase but I guess whatever quickly oh my
god that would have been huge for chase
she's like the biggest 11 year old on
Instagram her makeup tutorials are like
next-level
what Bricklin is 11 she looks like she's
30 yeah I said her makeup tutorials the
next level
you